bien qu'on nous annonçait il ya quelques
semaines encore une reprise vigoureuse
qui poursuivrait en 2022 et qu'en est il
aujourd'hui
il a d'abord bonjour grégory en fait les
perspectives pour 2020 2 sont désormais
marquée par une assez grande incertitude
il ya évidemment l'arrivée du vario
micron ça tout le monde va le comprendre
qu'ils plus contagieux mais qui peut
être aussi moins dangereux que le
variant delta et ça modifie la donne
après il ya de fortes probabilités pour
que l'activité économique soit
globalement impacté par la montée
absolument explosif de l'économie de
pardon de l'épidémie et du nombre de
contaminations au delà aidé il faut
savoir quand même que les problèmes
économiques se sont accumulées ces
dernières semaines voir dans le dernier
trimestre la désorganisation des chaînes
logistiques la persistance de
l'inflation dans de très nombreux
secteurs sont des facteurs qu'il faudra
prendre en compte enfin il y a quand
même ce qui se profile d'aidé à la fin
des aides et donc l'économie va revenir
dans un monde plus réel et cela ne sera
pas sans conséquences jacques la
première question
qui se pose c'est celle de la croissance
2022 est ce qu'elle sera aussi bonne
qu'espéré cette année-là alors ce qu'on
constate déjà c'est que pratiquement
dans l'ensemble de nos partenaires des
biens les prévisions sont en train
d'être révisée très fortement à la
baisse ça a été le cas en allemagne et
ça a été le cas au royaume uni en
espagne et même en italie qu'en france
normalement après une reprise de 6 7% on
escompte et pour 2022 et des
perspectives qui était plus favorable
elles ont été baissés b 2 0 1 point par
la banque de france et cette révision
par est finalement très bénigne et elle
n'est pas cohérente en réalité avec ce
que l'on sait du niveau d'activité de
nos principaux partenaires donc je
crains qu'il ne faille s'attendre à de
nouvelles révisions durant l'année 2022
en tous les cas durant le premier
trimestre l comment est-ce qu'elle
s'explique sa révision
alors ces révisions s'expliquent par un
élément conjoncturel et par un élément
structurel l'élément conjoncturel j'en
ai déjà parlé c'est évidemment
l'épidémie de variole kron et son impact
sur l'économie vous savez qu'on s'attend
à ce que le pic soit vers la nuit voire
la fin janvier donc cela va entraîner
une très forte des organisations de
l'activité économique du fait du nombre
important de personnes contaminées plus
des cas contactez les arrêts maladie
vont très probablement exploser d'ici la
fin du mois après il faut quand même
savoir qu'il y à un phénomène qui est
plus structurel c'est évidemment les
pénuries de matières premières les
pénuries de produits manufacturés c'est
bien la pénurie des microprocesseurs et
ses pénuries limite actuellement le
redémarrage de la production dans de
très nombreux secteurs elles vont
continuer à se faire sentir pendant au
moins le premier semestre de 2022 voire
plus alors même si des pays commence à
en voir le bout c'est le cas du japon en
particulier qui semble avoir surmonté le
phénomène des pénuries qui désorganisent
la production eh bien elles vont
continuer d'être un frein extrêmement
important reprise de l'activité en
france au moins je vous le dis sur la
première moitié de cette année mais
jacques que ses révisions vous remettre
en cause la baisse du chômage qu'on
constate ces derniers mois oui
absolument gégory absolument on ne
pourra pas avoir les prévisions qui sont
fait actuellement et ce d'autant plus
que le gouvernement comme un certain
nombre de journalistes malheureusement
ne traite pas de manière très rigoureuse
les statistiques du chômage il se
focalise sur la fameuse catégorie à bon
que l'on voit c'est là c'est la ligne
bleu sur le graphique qui vient de
s'afficher autrement dit les personnes
sans emploi et faisant une recherche
active d'emploi mais il oublie qu'il ya
deux autres catégories qui sont dans les
chômeurs c'est d'abord la catégorie b c
à les gens qui travaillent moins de 20
heures par mois et puis la catégorie d
et là ce sont les gens qui sont sans
emploi mais qui ont été pour des raisons
administratives
dispensé de faire une recherche active
alors ce qui est important de comprendre
c'est que oui effectivement
le chômage a fortement baissé pour la
catégorie à
c'est une catégorie ou par rapport au
pic que l'on avait connu en avril 2020
et d y ait une réduction de 1 million
200 mille personnes dans cette catégorie
a et on se retrouve actuellement sous le
niveau de décembre 2019 donc on peut
dire ça va bien mais si on prend les
catégories b et d là on voit que le
niveau est en fait supérieur d'environ
quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes par rapport au niveau 2
décembre 2019 et si maintenant on
considère ce qu'on appelle le quasi
chômage autrement dit les catégories c e
c'est à dire les gens qui sont au si
vous voulez et qui sont à mi temps de
manière contrainte et puis les gens qui
sont dans des emplois aidés et qui sans
ces aides effectivement ces emplois
n'existerait pas eh bien on constate que
le nombre global de gens qui sont dans
les catégories c et e et bien lui il a
augmenté de 200 milles par rapport à ce
qu'il était en novembre décembre
2019 au total nous nous retrouvons
toujours avec
6,1 6,2 millions de demandeurs d'emploi
autrement dit un chiffre qui est
équivalent à 2019 et alors si on doit
malheureusement s'y attendre la reprise
se ralentit en 2022 eh bien il est très
clair que le mouvement de retour à
l'emploi qui concerne il faut le
rappeler est essentiellement la
catégorie ya et bien ce mouvement de
retour à l'emploi va se ralentir à se
stabiliser en fait mais si la situation
devait empirer autrement dit si on avait
des problèmes économiques qui devait
perdurer au delà du premier semestre eh
bien il faut craindre que l'on connaisse
probablement à l'horizon du quatrième
trimestre 2022 une nouvelle dégradation
importante en ce qui concerne le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi mais jacques il
ya un autre problème aussi c'est de
l'inflation et donc du pouvoir d'achat
vous avez tout à fait raison des gaules
vous avez tout à fait raison l'inflation
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui est
forte elle est de 2
% en france sur l'année elle est aussi
importante en allemagne et elle était
encore beaucoup plus haute aux états
unis alors la question c'est de savoir
si nous sommes en face d'une inflation
qui est purement conjoncturelle outre
envie liés aux baigneurs est liée au
goulot d'étranglement bien si elle a une
dimension qui est plus structurel
ce qui va dans le sens d'une inflation
conjoncturel c'est que effectivement on
a tous ce phénomène des pénuries des
goulots d'étranglement et on peut penser
que là ce pic d'inflation eh bien il
devrait durer
jusqu'à la fin du premier semestre de
2022 voire le début du deuxième semestre
2000 22 avril devrait se tasser
progressivement seulement il faut déjà
savoir qu'il devrait provoquer une
baisse du pouvoir d'achat de 0 5% au
premier semestre de 2022 et qu'en
réalité cette baisse sera probablement
plus importante en particulier pour les
faibles revenus autrement dit pour les
gens qui sont dans les quatre premiers
déciles à des revenus est ce que l'on
sait moins c'est que la crise de lakovic
19 a provoqué une baisse de la
productivité du travail est cette meuf
va certainement durer durant l'ensemble
de l'année 2022 voit au delà or qui dit
baisse de la productivité dit aussi
évidemment hausse des coûts de
production
et s'il y a de hausse des coûts de
eh bien il est évident qu'il y aura
globalement une hausse des prix enfin il
faut comprendre que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un contexte qui est
assez différent avec le contexte de 2019
et pour différentes raisons d'abord ya
évidemment tous les investissements que
l'on veut faire pour gérer une mettre en
place la transition énergétique pour
lutter grosso modo contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est très bien
il faut aussi faire des investissements
pour d'autres choses en particulier dans
les services publics mais qui dit un
gros effort d'investissement
dit aussi une certaine manière
nécessairement un effet inflationniste
et puis on a les politiques des banques
centrales qui pour soutenir l'économie
ont énormément à injecter de monnaie
dans cette économie ce qui provoque
évidemment aussi des tensions
inflationnistes
la conclusion de tout cela c'est que la
question du pouvoir d'achat va être au
centre des préoccupations des français
et ce dans une année électorale
voilà qui ne va pas simplifier la tâche
du gouvernement ni celle du président
futur candidat donc les perspectives ne
sont pas encourageantes
mais vous savez grégory non payés en
plus un autre problème sur lequel
malheureusement légion sont vains les
responsables sont bien silencieux
actuellement et qui va se dévoiler très
probablement durant cette année c'est la
situation financière des entreprises
alors on sait que durant 2 milliards au
plus haut de la crise de la copie de
l'état a massivement aidé les
entreprises les il les a aidées
essentiellement par des garanties de
crédit alors que dans d'autres pays par
exemple comme en allemagne ou aux états
unis il a plutôt procédé à des
subventions alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire que ces garanties crise ça veut
dire que la charge d'endettement de
notre entreprise c'est en particulier le
cas pour les pme et les tpe s'est
alourdi or avec les situations
compliquées que l'on connaît dans le
domaine sanitaire et qui risque encore
de durer pour plusieurs mois eh bien il
est très clair que la consommation va
marquer le parc on sait qu'elles avaient
baissé la consommation de 7 % en 2020
elle avérée augmenté à près de 4,2 pour
cent en 2021 elle était donc pas du tout
revenu au niveau de 2019 est ce que l'on
peut penser c'est que elle ne reviendra
pas en 2022 ni même peut-être en 2023 au
niveau de 2019 alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire on a moins de consommation
c'était la moins de chiffre d'affaires
et même avec l'effet de l'inflation cela
veut dire que le flux de revenus sur
lequel on devrait payer les dettes
accumulées en 2000 en particulier à
travers les
ciboules et les prêts garantis par
l'état les fameux pge est bien loin de
moyens pour rembourser cela il ya donc
un risque réel de faillite à l'horizon
du deuxième semestre 2022 et dans ces
conditions la solution la moins mauvaise
serait que l'état reprenne à sa charge
une partie de l'endettement des
entreprises mais évidemment cela
poserait la question de la dette de
l'état donc jacques en conclusion une
année 2020 délicate qui s'annonce sur le
plan économique pour le gouvernement
mais aussi pour les français
ah oui les griots x est absolument
indiscutable les problèmes de court
terme de moyens d avoir de l'auterne
vont poser un problème tout à fait
redoutable au gouvernement l'année 2022
va être compliqué et pas seulement parce
qu'il s'agit d'une année électorale
quand il faudrait pour que le
gouvernement ne se perdent pas dans la
gestion de court voit de très court
terme autrement dit pour qu'il sorte la
tête du guidon ce qui est
malheureusement la situation dans lequel
il est actuellement qu'il dispose d'
orientation forte pour l'économie parce
que 2022 ça sera aussi une année
importante ça sera l'année dans laquelle
on doit rentrer dans le vif du sujet
pour la transition énergétique pour la
réindustrialisation de la france mais
aussi pour la housse il faut l'espérer
de la productivité tout cela cela
impliquerait que l'on ait une forme de
plan pour les années à venir
saoulé cette idée le président macro l'a
d'ailleurs eu il ad'ailleurs recréer un
dispositif qui s'appelle le haut
commissariat au plan qui est
actuellement présidée par monsieur
berrou en septembre 2020 seulement il en
a limité les fonctions à de la
prospective ce qui est une erreur grave
car on ne peut pas se priver d'un tel
instrument d'action dont le besoin se
fera de plus en plus sentir dans les
mois qui viennent il faudrait que ceux
haut commissariat au plan retrouve les
attributions de ce qu était dans les
années 50 60 et 70 le commissariat
général
blanc merci jacques sapir pour ce
panorama et économiques de l'année à
venir à la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel édito échos